ça vous a troublé qu'il soit là Johnny
Depp ou pas bien sûr que ces troublants
mais c'est pas à moi ministre de la
Culture de choisir quel va être le film
d'ouverture imaginez si je commence à
faire ça c'est la fin de la liberté de
programmation et c'est la fin du
festival de Cannes et en plus c'est un
film sur une femme Jeanne du Barry
plutôt invisibilisé par l'histoire
qu'elle veut remettre en lumière donc
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que juste
le sujet des violences
sous l'angle de la vie de Johnny Depp et
puis moi au fond ce qui m'importe
au-delà de ça c'est de voir que dans le
cinéma il y a des films qui nous aident
à changer de regard sur ces sujets même
là au Festival de Cannes le film de
Valérie Donzelli par exemple sur
l'emprise sur les relations toxiques
c'est un film passionnant
elle a raison
alors
elle va partout et on l'a invité ici à
la ministre de la Culture elle peut
venir on voit qu'elle a toujours bien
révisé en fait avant avant d'arriver on
sait que c'est un pote à mon avis c'est
qu'ils ont tous des conseillers il y a
le film de Valéry 2 minutes Rima il y a
le film de Valérie dansez oui qui est
cette personne va sur Wikipédia s'il te
plaît donc on voit quel est le récit le
Wikipédia à chaque fois c'est incroyable
donc si elle veut venir le réciter ici
c'est un grand plaisir on l'a invité
maintien de fois la ministre de la
Culture elle fait tout elle fait
Télématin c'est très sympa Télématin
mais si vous voulez prendre de la
notoriété vous serez plus regarder ici
vous serez plus ici non mais c'est vrai
voilà adore Télématin c'est très sympa
j'adore mais c'est vrai qu'elle sera
plus vue ici hein voilà je lui dis elle
fait ce qu'elle veut elle peut venir et
puis en plus c'est sympa on pourra lui
dire tout ce qu'on pense c'est vrai que
ça sera moins voilà c'est moins ce sera
moins sécurisé il va falloir plus
réviser parce que là voilà il y a des
cases bonbons autour
elle vient quand elle veut ça sera avec
plaisir oui alors qu'est-ce qu'elle a
alors
[Rires]
merci Madame d'être là avec plaisir
alors ce qui s'est passé c'est que elle
sait à l'armée auprès de Thomas Sotto
dans Télématin que Johnny Depp soit venu
au Festival de Cannes alors comme vous
le savez il est à l'affiche du film de
My Wayne du Barry et il a fait ce film
et en fait il a fait ce film a fait
l'ouverture du festival de Cannes et
pour 7 minutes Johnny Depp a été
applaudit sans cesse
et c'est ça qui a défrisés
notamment avec à la tête Julie Gayet
Géraldine Nakache qui se sont insurgés
contre le Festival de Cannes en disant
que le Festival de Cannes invité les
hommes et les femmes qui agressent en
faisant référence en fait au procès il a
gagné oui donc c'est un peu il a gagné
il a gagné son procès donc on regarde
donc alors oui donc voilà donc c'est ça
et du coup elle s'est dit oui c'est
assez troublant que Johnny Depp soit
invité au festival de Cannes et qui soit
accueilli de cette façon mais en même
temps je suis ministre de la Culture je
suis presque personne pour rien dire
mais en même temps elle dit des choses
voilà le directeur général du Festival
de Cannes annoncé qui ne dépend au
courant de l'affaire
oui qui s'en foutait de la vie privée
alors faut quand même savoir que ce
procès a duré plus de 7 semaines que il
a fait la l'éti de tout de tous les
journaux que en plus on avait plein de
détails de malade assez glauque sur
cette histoire c'est vrai que ce ce
procès s'est terminé par par une
victoire pour Johnny Depp qui a été
puisque Amber Heard a été condamné à 15
millions de dollars à l'université ce
qui est énorme et pour diffamation et
lui a dû lui verser 2 millions de
dollars donc dans la balance voilà 15
millions qui a été condamné pour
diffamation exactement donc voilà donc
ça peut une histoire mais un peu enfin
voilà on revient avec du meetou à part
que lui il a été voilà des douanes de
cette histoire non
elle était quand même énervée voilà mais
Thomas Soto il a pas dit dans
l'interview que Johnny Depp que Amber
heart son exam avait été condamné pour
des formations
on l'invite vraiment parce qu'elle fait
beaucoup de plateaux voilà elle peut
venir ici et avec plaisir on peut
l'inviter de la semaine prochaine si
elle veut j'ai quelques dispo
donc on a quelques dispo elle peut venir
à raconter le si elle veut venir lundi
ça c'est pas mal le jour de la Pentecôte
hein ce serait pas mal qu'elle vienne à
la ministre de la Culture mais non on
travaille pas c'est fait à raison
administrat avant ça voulait dire
maintenant ça veut plus rien dire agenda
de ministre maintenant ça veut dire j'ai
beaucoup de télé à faire les mecs je
peux pas avec Thomas to et puis le soir
dans les amours ça existe même plus ce
qu'elle a dit c'est clairement du
sexisme anti-homme et moi je me pose
avec la question si Amber Heard était
venu au Festival de Cannes est-ce
qu'elle aurait poussé le même coup de
gueule en dehors qui a été condamné pour
devant que Johnny Depp elle aurait rien
elle aurait rien dit du tout donc là
c'est du sexisme Antium et c'est
insupportable et je trouve qu'elle donne
beaucoup son avis sur tout et n'importe
quoi au lieu de promouvoir la culture
c'est sa mission primaire bah non mais
sur la connexion
médiatique il y a d'autres mises de la
culture
non mais son métier c'est plus de lancer
des initiatives et de faire la promotion
de la culture
malgré tout la culture et de personnes
de la culture qui ont signé cette tribu
sachant que il aurait été éventuellement
innocenté mais c'est pas si clair que ça
et à ce moment-là pourquoi il y a
beaucoup de femmes artistes actrices
c'est ça qui se sont insurgés de sa
présence
qui a été sanctionné de 15 jours
de la diffamation ils en reste toujours
quelque chose de la calomnie donc
forcément les gens ils ont peut-être ça
dans la tête tu vois parce qu'elle a été
condamné 10 millions de dollars de
dommages intérêts compensatoire et 5
millions de dollars de dommages et
intérêts punitifs
et donc voilà mais
oui il l'a pas frappé excusez-moi
excusez-moi et je défends je trouve le
projet je suis désolé scandaleux
de Johnny Depp je suis désolé moi c'est
lui bah oui
quand même sa femme excuse-moi un moment
ou un autre et on en fait des caisses
avec certains qui ont à peine un petit
doigt et lui
je suis désolé
quand même des choses je ne suis pas la
seule peut-être autour de la table mais
pas dans le vrai dans la vraie vie donc
j'ai le droit de le dire après je dis
pas que j'ai raison mais c'est mon
ressenti ils sont là excuse-moi voilà
donc après voilà après c'était où il
invitait pas du tout voilà et ou bien
voilà là maintenant qu'il est là tu vois
pas préférer ça moi j'aurais préféré
qu'on l'invite pas parce que signer des
tribunes moi j'aurais préféré que toutes
les actrices qui signent des tripes des
tribunes on l'avait déjà eu avec les
Césars je préfère qu'elle boycottes quel
boycottes dans votre cinéma de votre
mascarade avec des gens accusés les gars
de viol j'y vais viennent elles prennent
les Césars elles prennent les
récompenses frais prennent les petits
fours elles vont soirée et après c'est
une des tribunes n'y allez pas y aller
il a raison
[Rires]
de la cérémonie des César pourtant en
colonie deux semaines après signer les
contrats avec les mêmes gens pas
Géraldine laquelle arrêter alors
bravo
on est comme ça regardez tous ces films
ouais bah voilà bah bravo bravo